아 달러 약세
돈이 빠져나오면 중요한 건 이거예요
돈이 어디로 갔는지 우리가 봐야 돼요
그래 맞아
그래서 사실은 그때가 되면
어떤 거대한 투자의 시대의 서막이죠
일단 첫 번째는 빚달러
두 번째는 원자재 수입 의존도가 높은 나라
유가나 이런 원유나 이런 거 수입 의존도가 높은 나라
대만
한국이잖아요
일본
한국
뭐 여러 나라가 있죠 굉장히 많죠
그리고 또 하나는 저는 부채 비율이
정부 부채 비율이 그렇게 높지 않은 나라
한국
그러니까 이
코스피 랜더야 코스피
진짜 두 터베이크가 계속 코스피대로 해
땀나?
아니 원자재 수입이 높고
코스피 6만?
네 니니가 픽한 미장 수익 100% 절세 계좌
5월 안에 국내 주식에 복귀하면 양도세 0원
거래 수수료도 0원인 우리 슈퍼 RIA 계좌
많은 사랑 부탁드립니다
세월이 참 빠른 거 같아요
저 RIA 계좌 처음 나왔을 때 언제까지 들어오면 100% 면제고
기간이 늦게 들어오면 75%
1년 뒤인가 들어오면 50%
하주겠다 뭐 이런 걸 했었거든요
한참 남았다 생각했는데
마감이 올해 5월이라고 합니다
진짜 5월이에요?
그럼요
올까지만 해야 100% 면제될까요?
5월 말까지
5월까지 들어오면 세금 면제 세금 면제
세금 100% 면제
예별365 계좌 많이 사랑해주세요
자 좋습니다
자 2부
야 저도 글로만 뵌 분인데
저그전 아니고 이그전
이그전
예 저도 이 실물을 처음 뵌 것 같습니다
아유 안녕하십니까
네 안녕하십니까
안녕하세요 반갑습니다
반갑습니다
평소에 혹시 머니코믹스라든지 슈카월드라든지?
좀 아시고 계셨나요?
저는 슈카월드 굉장히 좋아합니다
오오?
제가 유일하게 항상 추천하는 프로그램
왜요? 어떤 면에서?
왜냐면은
이게 말씀도 재밌게 하는데
저도 이제 이런 분석하는 직업을 갖고 있잖아요
재밌으려면 사실
핵심이 뭔지를 딱 파악해서 알려주는 게 중요하거든요
아 요점 정리
아니 근데 핵심을
되게 파악을 빨리 하세요
아 진짜로
여러분 저 정말 훌륭하신 분이십니다
역시
역시 훌륭하신 분이에요
오늘은 어떤 얘길 좀 준비해 주셨습니까?
네 오늘은 이제 뭐
어떤 거 할까 하다가
조금 딱딱한 주제일 수도 있는데
트럼프의 이란 사태가 터졌잖아요
그 이후에 이제 어떻게 세상이 흘러갈까
경제 관점에서 좀 생각하는 것들
그리고 트럼프의 이란 전략들도 어떻게 흘러갈까
이런 것들을 좀 재밌게 한번 풀어 보려고
오 좋습니다
전체적으로 한번
댓글을 한번 짚어주시는 그런 이제 저희가 정리하는 시간으로 한번 가면 좋을 것 같습니다.
댓글에 니들이 잘 모를 텐데 은택이 형은 네임드야.
형 유명했어?
주로 남자들이 많이 했나 보죠.
그렇죠. 남자들 많습니다.
형밖에 없네요.
요즘에 저는 개인적으로 트럼프 대통령의 말을 보면 좀 불안불안한 게 멘탈이 좀 괜찮으신가.
아 그것까진 모르겠는데.
좀 정신적으로 꽉 잡고 계신가 아니면 너무 온탕과 냉탕을 왔다 갔다 하시니까.
알 수가 없어.
근데 이분이 하는 얘기를 보면 되게 왔다 갔다 하는데 그 패턴이 되게 일관적이에요.
사실 2018년 1기 때 했던 것과 2기 때 무역협상 했던 것과 이란 전쟁이 패턴이 다 똑같아요.
한번 제가 기사만 몇 개 보여드리면 아마 혁돌 거예요.
좋습니다.
1기 때입니다. 2019년 때.
갑자기 무슨 얘기를 하시나요?
무슨 얘기를 하냐면 트럼프가 그런 얘기해요. 중국 필요 없어. 관세 더 때리겠어. 관세를 하니까 이때 중국이 폭락했죠.
이제 전쟁이 끝나지 않나 보다.
갑자기 30일 만에 기자회견 앞에서 기자들 앞에서 그런 거예요.
중국에서 전화가 왔다. 협상을 원한다고.
갑자기?
갑자기 얘기를 하는 거예요.
그래서 기자들이 깜짝 놀라서 그날 새벽에 바로 아침에 중국에 달려와서 물어봤어요.
왜 전화했습니까?
중국에.
어? 난 전화한 적이 없는데?
대화하는 사실도 없는데?
그래서 기자들이 또 물어봐요. 다음 날.
진짜 전화 왔습니까?
중국에서 안 했다는데요. 그랬더니 뭐라고 하냐면 오늘은 어나더 레벨의 어떤 사람이 전화한다.
더 위에 있는 사람.
더 윗선에서.
중국은 거래를 원하고 있다.
이게 사실은 이번에 한 3, 4주 전인가요?
이란에서 했던 얘기 똑같죠.
이란에서 갑자기 협상을 해달라고 연락이 왔다.
패턴이 똑같네.
이란에 물어보니까 우리는 연락한 적 없다.
이게 똑같고.
누가 코라를 치는 거예요? 죄송합니다. 표현 좀 그런데.
이미 느낌은 있지 않습니까? 누군지.
전작을 모르겠었어.
사쿠라.
2기 때도 사실 똑같았어요.
이때도 이제 관세를 중국한테 145%나 올렸죠.
그러고 나서는 갑자기 이제 전쟁 안 끝나나 봐 라고 했는데 4월 17일에 갑자기 트럼프가 전화가 왔다 또.
전화 왔다.
중국에서 연락이 왔다. 대화 중이다. 이런 거예요.
그래서 물어봤더니 중국이 우린 그런 바 없고 협상 안 할 거다 이런 거예요.
그래서 또 물어봤더니 이번에는 똑같아요. 어나더 레벨.
이러면 시진핑이 전화가 왔다.
기사 찾아보면 지금도 있을 거예요.
그래서 기자들이 물어봅니다. 언제 전화가 왔고 무슨 얘기를 했습니까?
그때 그 시점과 내용은 말해줬어.
국가기밀.
안 왔을 것 같죠. 왠지 전화가.
그렇게 보니까 한결같긴 하네.
이런 것들이 되게 똑같아요.
국가 지도자가 저렇게 해도 되나.
이 생각이 약간 들긴 하는데.
해도 된다고 생각하는 것 같아요.
해도 돼. 해도 돼.
그다음에도 똑같아요. 갑자기 이날도 그래요.
거래를 원한다고 해놓고는 바로 그 다음날 뭐합니까?
1일부터 중국에게 추가 관세.
진짜 이상하다.
근데 협상은 계속.
우리도 이거 경험한 적이 있어요.
2기 때도 이거 했고.
얼마 전에는 한 3주 전인가요?
협상한다고 해놓고 기자회견 하겠다.
트럼프 발표했잖아요.
협상한다는 발표인가 보다 했더니
앞으로 2주에서 3주 동안 융단폭격.
이란의 문명을 지워버릴 거야.
이런 얘기 했잖아요.
그날 주가 폭락해가지고
다시 5천 포인트.
그 전저점을 깼죠.
하지만 협상은 계속.
근데 이게 재밌는 게 트럼프만 똑같이 하는 거야.
시장이 속는 패턴도 똑같아요.
어떻게 안 속아요.
스토리지로 만들어 버리겠다 그러고
뉴클리어가 곧 누를 것 같지.
저렇게 얘기하시는데.
그걸 미국 대통령인데.
패턴 한번 보시면요.
이때도 뭐라고 나오냐면.
야 이제는 협상 없어.
만날 리가 없어.
싸우느라고 둘 다 너무 팽팽해 대립이.
그 다음에 무슨 얘기 나옵니까.
이제는 공격을 시작한 트럼프가 더 불리해졌어.
선거 앞둔 트럼프가 더 불리해.
이게 2기 때도 똑같은 얘기 나왔고.
이번에도 그랬잖아요. 오히려 1연이 더 유리해졌어.
이란이 협상할 리가 없어.
중국이 어떻게 했냐.
미국 농산물을 추가 구매해요.
이것도 내가 구매하겠어라고
공식 선언한 것도 아니고.
은근슬쩍 구매를 해요.
갑자기 뭐 바뀐 거 있니. 너도 주문 받았어.
너도 나도 주문을 받은 거예요.
이게 약간 대화하자.
새살배기들 싸우는 것도 아니고.
대화할 거면 대화하면 되지.
뒤로 그냥 흥.
잡았으면 네가 잡은 거다.
내가 잡은 거 아니다.
이런 느낌인데.
이걸 잘 몰랐어요. 트럼프가 이렇게 할 줄을.
2기 때는 이렇게 할 줄 알고
이렇게 하지 않겠냐.
진짜 이렇게 하더라고요.
이번 이란 때도 완전 똑같진 않지만
협상이 시작됐다. 연락 왔다.
이렇게 할 때부터는 주가 하락해도
그때부터는 사실은
타코.
타코가 나오는 거라는 것들을
어느 정도 예상을 할 수 있었어.
이 책 아시나요? 거래기술형 책.
있으신 분 있을 거예요. 집에.
여기 사실 다 나옵니다. 그대로 하시더라고요.
여기 구라 치는 게 나와요?
그대로 나옵니다.
그게 굉장히 효율적이다.
강화 압박하고 옵션은 항상
열어두고. 그다음에 또 판 깨고.
여기 다 나오네요.
글이 무시무시한 게
상대에게 무슨 짓이든 할 수 있는
사람처럼 보이게 하고
갑자기 긴장을 풀어 더 많은 양보를
끌어낸다.
이게 합의가 가능하냐. 이런 얘기들이 좀 있잖아요.
제가 볼 때는 합의가 가능할
가능성이 높다라고 생각하는데
트럼프식 합의라면
좀 생각해 볼 수 있지 않나 이런 생각이 들어요.
트럼프식 합의가 뭔지를 여기 잠깐 썼는데
첫 번째는 휴전을 꼭 합니다.
1기 때 2기 때 모두
90일 휴전을 해요.
90일 휴전을 해요. 중국이랑.
유예를 유예하더라고요.
맞아요. 맞아요.
그때도 유예했고
지금도 그래서 딱 2주가 나왔죠.
그럼 어떻게 되냐. 2주 넘어가면.
트럼프한테 이것도 중요한 게
2주 90일 이런 날짜 있잖아요.
이런 건 큰 의미가 없어요.
의미가 없는 겁니까?
48시간 최후 통처
그다음에
5일간 공격 유예
그다음에 추가 유예
2주에서 3주 동안 무제배험 폭격
한 번도 지켜본 적이 없어요.
24시간 또 유예도 나오고
유예했는데 그것도 아니고
5일간 공격을 유예한다고 했는데도
그때 계속 공격하고.
트럼프는 이거를 한 번도 지켜본 적이 없고
90일도 지켜본 적이 없고
2주도 제가 볼 때 안 지킬 거예요.
제 생각에는 아마 대통령 되기 전에
사업하면서 이런 거를 수십 번 해봤을 것 같아요.
걷는 것도 기술이구나.
이분한텐 그럴 수도 있죠.
이게 되네.
이거를 여러 번 해봤겠죠.
할 때마다 사람들이 다 비슷하게
쫄고 그 날짜에 체크해서 기다리고
협상하려고 그러더라.
이런 것들을 배우지 않았을까.
사업가만인데 진짜.
어쨌든 그래서 이번에도
그다음에 두 번째가 더 중요한데
트럼프식 합의라는 건 도대체 뭐냐.
이거는 1차 미중 관세 합의를 생각해보시면 돼요.
좀 오래전 일이에요.
2019년 10월이었는데.
1차에만.
트럼프가 최종 2차
최종까지 안 가면 내가 또다시
무자비하게 관세를 때리겠다.
이런 얘기를 했어요.
실제로 여기까지는 아마 아실 거예요.
그다음에 어떻게 되는지 아마
뉴스 잘 보실 거예요.
실제로 그래서 2차 합의를 위해서
워싱턴과 베이징을 오가면서
실무신들이 협상을 했어요.
결국에는 추가 합의에 실패했어요.
왜냐면 1차 합의는 그래도
서로 양보할 수 있는 것들 갖고 했거든요.
2차는 서로 양보할 수가 없는
첨예한 것들 갖고 한 거예요.
협의가 잘 안 된 거예요.
그래서 어떻게 됐냐.
관세 다시 때리고 전쟁했냐.
아니죠.
그냥 1차 합의했던 7.5% 대중 관세가
바이든 정부 때까지 그냥 그게 유지가 돼요.
그게 결국 최종 합의가 된 거예요.
성공한 건 아니에요?
트럼프 입장에서는?
성공일 수도 있죠.
왜냐하면 일단은 이게 필요한 건 먼저 하는 거예요.
그러면 이제 이렇게 생각할 수 있죠.
트럼프한테 좋은 거 아니냐 말이 되냐라고 하겠지만
제가 볼 땐 더 좋을 수도 있어요.
트럼프한테요?
왜냐하면 예를 들어서 생각해보세요.
최종 합의다 그랬어요. 이란이랑.
자, 최종 합의입니다.
보세요. 짠. 내가 이걸 했습니다.
그러면 딱 보면 뭐라고 하겠어요?
평론가들이나 아니면 반대파들이
이거 하려고 수만 사람을 죽이고
지금 이 난리를 쳤는 거냐.
오히려 우리가 뺏긴 거 아니냐.
와, 대박. 그러네요.
그거 아니고 이건 임시 합의야.
난 이 말 안 듣잖아. 그럼 내가 다시 공격해서
쑥대밭을 만들 거야.
이러면 약간 평론하기도 뻘쭘해요.
트럼프식 합의는
합의를 하도
했다가 안 했다가 물렸다가
이랬다가 저랬다가 해서 마지막이 좀
흐릿해져요.
합의가 된 건가?
그 뒤는 기억이 잘 안 나.
관세가 지금 중국이
얼마나 가고 얘기가 어떻게
돼가고 있지?
그러면 제가 하나 더 여쭤볼까요?
작년에 우리나라하고 미국하고 결국
7월 30일날 합의해서 이제 우리 경주
에이펙 오셨을 때 서명했잖아요.
그리고 그때 이제 불완전화 합의이기 때문에
그 이후에 계속 협의를 하겠다.
어떻게 된 줄 아세요? 어떻게 된지 모르겠어요.
계속 관세 내고 있어요.
트럼프 이전에 약 2.5%
에피페이하고 했으니까
실효 관세율이 2.5였는데 지금
한 13%예요. 이게 뉴노멀이 된 거예요.
그때만 해도 10%
관세는 우리나라는 어떻게 망하고
기업들이 힘들고 어쩌고 했는데
결과를 잘 몰라. 근데 우리
관세 내고 그냥 수출하고 있는 거예요. 우리가 내는 건 아니죠.
근데 저 결과를 알기가 너무 힘든 게
너무
이거를 뭐 갈짓자 행보를 하니까
저도 못 따라 하겠더라고요. 이게 어떻게 되는지
각 국가마다 다 다르고 막 이러니까
근데 어떻게 보면 그게 트럼프의 큰 그림이네요.
그냥 흐지부지하면서
나의 성과를 알지 못하게 하는 실패
이게 목표를 했는 건지 아니면 목표를 하지 않았는데
이렇게 끝나는 건지 모르겠지만
항상 이렇게 끝나는 거 보니까 최소한
이런 생각이 있는 것 같아요. 아 이렇게 합의해도
이 정도면 된 거야.
이번에도 이제 제일 문제는
그거죠. 불확실하다는 거. 이번에 또 이렇게 할 거냐
지금까지 이렇게 했지만
이번엔 다르지 하고 바꿀 수도 있죠.
그건 알 수 없지만 그래도 이런 패턴들을
알면은 아 트럼프가 이렇게 가는구나
를 좀 우리가 투자할 때
많이 참고해 볼 수가 있다.
말 그대로 타코를 좀
염두에 두셔라.
그럴 가능성이 지금까지 패턴들을 봤을 때는
있죠.
알겠습니다.
그래서 뭐 이그전이라고 아까 얘기하셨는데 이 자료에
그때 다 썼던 거예요. 이제 저번 달
말쯤에 뭐 이렇게 갈 것 같다.
전화 왔다? 안 왔다.
협상 했다? 안 했다.
사랑한다? 안 한다.
할 수도 있고 안 할 수도 있고.
하나씩 뽑으면서 사랑한다.
중국이랑도 비슷하죠.
절대 안 한다. 이제는 해놓고는 이제
슬그머니 이제 호르무수협에 몇 개
이렇게 배 보내주고 농산물
수입하면서 쪽지 딱 보내는 거죠.
그다음에 이제 사실 앞으로 어떤
일들이 생길 건지 이런 거에 대해서
우리가 한번 그 여러
경제학적인 이론으로 한번 쉽게
풀어보자 라고 해서 좀 갖고 왔어요.
문제는 뭐냐면은 제가 볼 때 이제
여러 가지 문제가 있겠죠. 근데 경제적으로 좀 주목할
문제는 이번 전쟁이나 이런 것 때문에
부채가 더 늘어날 거라는 거예요.
미국의 부채가. 감세하니까
세금은 더 안 걷고
뭐 이런 사태가 될 거예요. 그럼 부채가 더
늘어난다는 거죠. 그래서 금융화합 이런 걸
제가 작년 8월 레포트
인덱스하게 썼었는데
비슷한 현상들이 벌어지고 있었죠. 얘기를 해보겠습니다.
부채가 많긴 많은데 아마
부채가 많은 것
자체로는 그렇게 큰 문제는 되지 않아요.
항상 많아왔잖아요.
아마 대출 다 받아보셨잖아요.
채권도 해보셨고 그러면은
이자율만 낮으면 금리만 낮으면
금리가 0에서 1%
1점 몇 프로 이러면은
부채가 많아도 아주 심각한 문제가 되진 않아요.
왜냐면 상관 안 하는데 그렇게 큰 문제는 없으니까
부채는 언제부터 본격적인 문제가 되냐
여러 가지 케이스가 있지만 가장 큰 거는
물가가 올라서 금리가
솟구치기 시작할 때부터
그럼 이제 이자를 내야 되잖아요.
이자를 못 내게 되는 상황이 벌어지면
그게 가장 힘든 상황이에요. 그때부터
문제가 생겨요. 근데 미국이
지금 부채가 많았지만 그동안 어땠습니까?
이자율이 굉장히 낮았잖아요.
제가 여기 정리한 게 있는데
점선이 지금 미국 정보 내는 이자인데
작년까지만 해도 3%
초반 정도밖에 안 됐어요.
사실은 이 점선이 미국
10년물 금리거든요.
얘하고 비슷하게 가야 맞잖아요.
지금 얘는 거의 5% 찍었는데
얘는 3%밖에 안 됐었거든요.
올라가고 있네요. 여러 가지 이유가 있는데
이 텐데믹 때
채권 많이 찍었잖아요.
중단기 채권들. 그때 제로금리
거의 제로금리 찍다 보니까 그
채권들이 아직 남아 있어서
실제 금리는 올라갔는데 아직 이자 내는 거죠.
낮을 때 그니까 많이 땡겨놔가지고
금리가 낮았던 거예요.
미국 정부가 내는 이자율은 아직은 낮다.
그렇죠. 낮은데 이제 그게
다 소모가 되고 있어요. 그때 장기채는 잘 안 찍었으니까
지금부터 올라가기 시작하는 거예요.
가만히만 놔둬도 한 4%
초중반까지는 올라갈 것 같아요.
만약에 지금 뭐 유가가 올라가고
어쩌고 저쩌고 해가지고 6%만 돼도
사실 지금 3% 내던 거에
더블을 내야 돼요.
그런데 이게 지금 어느 정도냐
미국 정부가 내고 있는 이자가
GDP의 3.2%를 역대급으로
최고 수치예요.
현재 금리 수준에서도
이게 보통 논문들 보면은
4%부터 문제가 생기기 시작하고
5% 이상 되면
국가나 제국의 기반이 흔들린다고
되어 있어요. 과거 패턴들로 봤을 때
그런데 아까 보시다시피 금리가
6%만 돼도 이제는 이거에 더블이니까
GDP 대비 거의 5%
6%의 이자 비용을 지불을 해야 되는 거예요.
그러면 이거를
미국 정부가 낼 수 있느냐
이런 문제가 생기죠.
지금 갚을 거라고 생각 안 하고 있어요. 갚을 수가 없잖아요.
갚을 거라고 생각 안 하면 정말
이 금융 시스템에 엄청난 일이 벌어지는 거예요.
전에는 그렇게 생각하니까 문제가 있는 거예요.
이걸 갚을 수 있어요?
빚을 빌리면 갚아야지.
무슨 누구 돈으로 갚을 건데요.
네 돈으로 갚아야지. 네가 빌렸는데.
미국 정부의 부채를 누가 갚냐고.
미국이 갚아야지. 내가 갚겠어?
미국 정부의 부채를?
갚는 방법이 있습니다.
지금 부채 비율을 보세요.
GDP 대비 부채 비율을 보면은
지금이 역사상 가장 높았던 시기냐
부채 비율이 아니거든요.
2차 세계대전 이후에
1차 세계대전을 한 번 올랐다가 2차 하면서 빵 하고 올랐죠.
저 때는 지금보다 부채가 더 많았어요.
부채비율이 더 높았어요.
이런 생각이 들어요. 아 그럼 부채가 저렇게 높았으면
그때 경기는 굉장히 안 좋아지고
부채를 줄이지 못해서
미국의 패권이 흔들렸나? 아니거든요.
보시면 첫 번째
부채는 엄청난 속도로 떨어지죠.
엄청난 속도로 떨어져요.
엄청난 속도로 떨어져서 부채를
줄이는 데 성공을 했고
두 번째는 그 다음에
The golden age of capitalism이라고
부채의 황금기라는 시기가 1960년대에
펼쳐져요. 50년대 말에서 60년대에
굉장히 그때 미국이 많이
발전했던 시기죠. 그럼 미국
경제학자나 정치인들이 생각하지 않겠어요?
어? 이때 어떻게 했지 우리가? 어떻게 한 거예요?
금융어합이라는 방법을 써요.
뭐냐면은 한번 보세요.
이게 지금 차트가 좀 복잡해 보이는데
어렵지 않습니다.
이 굵은 색상은 초단기 금리. 그러니까 연준은 그냥
정책금리라고 생각하셔도 돼요. 3개월짜리니까
연준의 금리는 주로
지금 우리가 아는 거는 물가에 따라서
변동된다고 알고 있죠. 네.
중앙은행이 물가인데 두 개가 거의 비슷하게 가지 않습니까?
뭐 업사건이 기숙사건이 하면서
근데 아까 그 부채가
높았던 시기 있죠. 1940년대에서 50년대
초. 이때 어떻습니까? 물가가
15%, 20% 튀는데
금리는 1%
이하로. 이게 어떻게 된거지?
못 올렸다는 거죠? 부채가 많아서.
그렇죠. 이게
정부는 개인이나 기업하고
달라요. 자기 스스로에게
연준을 이용해서 금리를 낮출 수 있는
힘이 있는 거예요. 약간 그럼 있잖아요.
중앙은행의 독립성이 이제 훼손되는 거 아니냐
막 비난하지만 사실은 그렇게 갈 수밖에
없는 상황들도 마련되어 있는 거죠. 왜냐면은
금리가 튀면은 못 갚거든요.
이런 일이 벌어질 수 있는 거예요.
근데 여기서 이제 문제들이 몇 개 발생하죠.
보세요. 물가가 튀는데
물가가 15% 20%인데
금리는 1%밖에 안 줘요. 그럼 어떻게 되죠?
경기침체가 계속 발생하고 물가가 막 높아질 수밖에
없는 거예요. 금리를 강제로 낮추니까
그래서 보시면 이때 그래서 물가가 막
13%
20%까지 막 튀어요. 그러면서 경기침체가
발생을 하죠. 근데 여기서 이게
아까 보셨듯이 2차 세계대전
이후에 경제성장과 부채를
끌어내렸던 정말 큰 키가 됐던 거예요.
뭐냐. 물가가 이렇게 오르잖아요. 그러면 어떻게 됩니까?
일단은 금리를 낮췄으니까
이자 비용이 줄어들죠. 이게 하나가 이제 커요.
두 번째는 물가가
튀니까 실질 부채 명목의
명목의 부채 가치가 줄어드는 거예요.
무슨 얘기인지 아시겠나요? 이거 좀 어려운 얘기인데
어려워요. 아
슈커쌤 도와주세요. 네가 1억을 빌렸어
아 지금 빚 때문에
10억을 빌렸어. 빚이 너무 커
안 되겠다. 에라
인플레이다. 그래서
옆에서 먹던 밥이 만 원짜리가 10만 원이 되고
통화값이 똥값이 돼
그럼 내비 10억은
개꿀. 별거 아니네. 맞아.
그렇게 된다는 거죠.
그럴까 몰라서. 그래서 이제 뭐
통화를 개똥값으로 만들면 된다는
인플레를 이용해서 부채를 녹일 거다.
정부가 그런 걸 할 거다.
얘기들은 많이 나오는데 사실 이게 정확히 말하면은
음모론적으로 뭐 국민들을
골탕 먹이기 위해서 인플레를 만드는 게 아니에요.
그게 아니라 아까 보셨던 것처럼
이자를 낼 수가 없는 상황이 됐어.
어쩔 수 없는 선택인 거예요. 정부는
이자를 못 내면 어떡해. 파산할 수는 없잖아.
그럼 어떡해요. 이 방법 쓸 수밖에
없는 거야. 그러니까 이런 거죠.
너가 빚이 10억이야. 네
근데 네 금리를 네가 정할 수 있어.
어? 내가? 네 대출금리를.
근데 지금 막 물가가 올라. 네. 물가를
잡기 위해서 네 대출금리를 올려야 돼.
근데 빚이 10억이어서 대출금리를
그러면 올리면 안 될 거 같아.
네. 어떻게 할 거예요. 어떻게 해야 돼
지금. 4만 원이 가야 돼요. 아니 아니
다시 다시 다시. 자 10억이니까
네 빚이 50억이야. 50억이야.
안 돼. 50억이야. 네. 지금 대출금리가
1%야. 1%야. 또는 0%야. 네.
그래서 거의 이자를 안 내. 안 내. 괜찮아.
괜찮아. 응. 근데 이제 막 물가가
오른대. 물가가 올라. 근데 금리를 네가
정할 수 있어. 오. 자
물가를 위해서 금리를 올려야 돼. 네
대출이자 때문에 금리를 낮게
유지해야 돼. 0으로 하지 그러면.
그렇지. 금리를 0으로 하지. 네. 0으로 해야 돼. 그 얘기하는 거
아닙니까. 그거야. 물가가 아무리 올라오면 금리
안 올린다고. 아아아아아.
그렇죠. 근데 우리는 그렇게 할 수가
없잖아요. 0을 하고 싶어도 0을 할 수 없는데
국가는 그런 힘이 있는 거죠. 국가는 할 수 있지.
너 0. 0. 그럼 물가가 막 올라.
응. 내 50억 빚이 똥값이 되면서
옛날로 치면 한 15억으로 떨어져. 네.
아이고 좋다 하면서. 아아.
빚은 뭐 이렇게 통화가치 때문에 줄어드는 것처럼
된다. 지금 말씀하신 거잖아요. 그렇죠. 그러니까 대통령이 부르는
의장 불러서. 어. 잘하자. 너 0으로 해라.
어. 금리 낮춰. 어. 그렇죠. 0으로 해라.
50pp 100pp 날이란 말이야. 네. 개이든.
그러고 있다는 거죠. 그렇죠. 근데 그거를
어떻게 보면은 연중의장도
받아들일 수밖에 없는 게. 그렇지. 방법이 없잖아.
방법이 없잖아요. 응. 그리고 이제 마지막
세 번째. 그게 어떻게 경제성장을 갖고 왔냐. 처음엔
경기침착이 보세요. 세 번이나 빠지잖아요. 거의 뭐
한 3, 4년 내에 한 번씩 계속 빠져요. 네.
그러다 보니까 어떻게 됩니까?
물가는 높은데 금리는 낮아. 그러니까 어느
순간인가 경제가 조금 안정되니까. 어. 이거 봐라.
1%짜리로 대출 받아가지고
물가상승률 정도만 먹어도 경제가
발전. 내가 돈 많이 먹을 수 있겠네. 오. 오.
맞네. 그런 이제 용자들이 생기기 시작하는 거예요.
아. 대박. 그런 사람들이 이제 사업가 정신으로 이제
쫙 비즈니스 하면서 경제 점점
살아나는 거예요. 오. 그래서
니가 레버리지만 하나?
오. 그래서 니가 두 배만
하니? 네. 아니 그런
용기를 안 내면 돈을 벌 수가 없잖아요.
그때도 그런 용자들이 돈을
번 거잖아요. 뭐 그럴 수 있겠죠. 대출이
이렇게 싸니까. 그치. 니는 결론이
이상한 데로 갔어요.
결론이. 어. 근데
질문이 있습니다. 그때는 그랬는데
지금은 금리 낮춘다는 얘기가 없고
금리를 올린다고 하는데. 아. 이건요.
이게 이제 뒤에서 말씀드리겠지만 이렇게 하면은
엄청난 후폭풍이 와요.
이거를 쉽게 할 수가 없어요. 음.
이렇게 하면은 후폭풍이 와요.
누가 후폭풍이냐고? 너한테 50억 빌려준
내가 열받는다. 정답이죠.
내 50억을 뭐
물가를 올려서 꼬르륵 해놓고
금리는 1%를 주고. 맞네.
뒤에서 말하겠지만 미국한테
이제 국채 사서 돈 빌려준 국가가 있을 거
아니에요. 맞네. 물가가 15%인데
난 1% 준대. 네.
거기 있겠습니까? 그치. 다 빼는 거죠.
돈 줘야지. 다 빼는 거죠.
그러면 그 경제가 버티겠어요?
못 버티죠. 그게 쉽지 않죠.
그래서 그렇기 때문에 쉽게
결정하지 못해요. 음.
이때는 또 온도 되게 잘 맞춰 떨어져요.
이거 먼저 한번 하고 갈까요? 네. 그래서 인플레이션이 저는
유발된다라는 게
유발될 가능성이 있죠. 근데 정부의 음모론이
아니고 어쩔 수 없는 선택이 될
가능성이 있다. 근데 우리는 여기서 이제
일단 투자자들 하나 알아야 돼요.
인플레이션. 우리 고등학교 때 해보죠. 인플레이션이
유리한 주체들. 음. 불리한
주체들. 그쵸? 뭐 유리한 주체는
채무자. 돈을 빌리는 사람 아까. 돈 빌려서
사업 한번 올려도 더 좋겠네. 많은 사람들. 네.
실물자산 투자자. 그쵸?
실물자산 올라오니까 뭐
가격 결정력이 있는 기업. 그렇지. 이것도 되게
중요한 얘기인 게요. 워렌 버핏이나
이런 뭐 피터 린치 이런 우리가
같이 투자자들이 돈을 언제 거기다 벌었나
보시면 대부분 70년대
80년대 90년대 초까지 다 벌었어요.
음. 뭐 그 시즈 캔디
뭐 이런 거 막 맥도날드 이런 거 하잖아요.
네 네. 뭐 코카콜라. 그런 기업이 어떤
기업이냐면 시장 장악력이 굉장히 높잖아요.
네. 필수 소비자는 아니지만 일단 뭐
그 식품이기 때문에 수량으로 막
마트처럼 막 이게 성장하기 힘들어요.
음. 하지만 인플레이션이 오른다. 어? 인플레이션
10% 올랐어? 그럼 가격 10% 올리지 뭐.
네. 그러면은 내가
물건을 10% 덮어놔서 매출을
올리는 것과 네. 가격을
10% 올려가지고 매출 10% 올리는 건
똑같아요. 그래서 같이 투자자들이
돈을 번 이유가 가격 결정력이
있는 기업들이 거의 다 이제 뭐 작은
작은 회사라도 장악력이 굉장히 큰
기업. 음. 시즈 캔디 굉장히 작지만
사람들이 그거 가격이 올라가고 먹잖아요. 근데 먹으니까.
네. 그런 기업들은
매출 올리기가 되게 쉬워요. 어.
어. 그런 기업들이 이제 보통 인플레이션이
나오면은 가치도가 잘 되죠. 음. 그럼
반대로 인플레이션이 별로 없을 땐 뭐가
잘 되겠습니까? 성장주 투자가 잘 되죠.
아. 지난 20년 동안 그런 세상에서
우리가 살았던 거잖아. 10년 동안. 아.
그렇죠. 이제 불리한 주체를 보겠습니다.
인플레이션 불리한 주체.
현금 예금 예금자들. 아.
그래. 네. 임금근로자 연금소득자.
절약거지. 채권투자자. 다 누굽니까?
저요. 다 우리예요.
작년. 저요?
축하신 분들 법인계좌 수익률. 그렇지.
3%. 가만히 있었잖아.
3.3%인가? 절약거지 계좌 됐어.
어떻게 된 겁니까 위원님? 그래서
이게. 제가 술수에 놀아난 건가요?
인플레이션으로. 피해자야 피해자.
녹아나고 있던 겁니까? 음. 그렇진 않죠.
그건 정확하게 그건 아니지만 어쨌든
투자했으면 더 좋은 결과가 있어.
쉬었음 돈. 쉬었음 돈은 뭐야?
야 누구야? 쉬었음 돈은 뭐냐?
쉬었음 돈. 일을 안 하고 쉬었어.
이런 일이 벌어졌기 때문에 우리가
일단 이거 알고 있어야. 네. 우리가
이용을 해먹을 수 있다는 거죠. 왜냐면 우리는
불리한 주체 있으니까. 음. 좋아.
필요한 정보였어. 이거는 좀
복잡한 얘기인데 아마 아실 거예요. 근데 단기물은
단기금리는 연준
중화은행이 딱 정하면은 거기 안에서
놀 수 있지만 장기금리는 그렇게 못하잖아요.
네. 장기금리는 왜냐하면은
시장에서 결정되기 때문에
그렇게 하면 다 도망갈 거 아니야. 자국돈이.
그래서 그 당시에 뭐 했냐.
자국돈을 묶어놓는 게 굉장히 중요하고. 미국에서
밖으로 안 나가게. 아. 그래서 다
막아놨어요. 그래서 이 당시에 실제로 자본통제를
실시했는데 미국에서 한 정책이에요.
네. 외화자산 및
취득 및 보유 금지. 해외송금
및 외환거래 규제. 허가받지
않으면 할 수 없죠. 아유. 달러 유출
금지. 네. 금 보유 금지.
외화투자 금지. 음.
못 나가게 한 거야. 당시 미국에서 그랬다는 거죠?
당시 미국에서. 달러만 써라. 달러만 투자해라. 대단하죠.
근데 이게 성공했을 수 있지. 지금은
이게 잘 안 되겠죠. 근데 이때 성공했을 수도
있었던 이유 중에 하나가 뭐냐면 저기 4번에
좀 멀찌감치 적어놨는데 대체투자
처의 부재. 미국 제외하면?
맞아요. 유럽은 전쟁 나서
더 날리고 거기다 돈 넣었다가는
다 띄는 거죠. 전쟁난 나라에
야 난 너네 나라 투자할게 하면 오 땡큐
하면서 갚겠습니까? 안 갚죠.
일본 마찬가지고. 어차피 살 때가 없어.
소련하고 그 당시 중공은 공산화됐고. 네.
나갈 데가 없는 거야. 네.
그러니까 좋으나 나쁘나 그냥 그래도 여기
원금은 안 띄니까 미국은. 네. 1% 중에
있으니까 문제지만 원금은 안 띄니까
그냥 여기다 다 넣어. 아오.
딴 것도 있어요. 워본드라서 전쟁채권을
발행해서 애국심을 자극해요.
그래서 친구들한테
물어봤대요. 너 월급 받은 거 워본드
샀어 안 샀어? 너 안 샀어?
너 뭐 매국노야? 이런 식의 분위기를
조장하고 그렇게 했대요.
그래서 무조건 국채를 사게끔. 그래야
금리를 낮춰서 이자 비용을 정부가
안 낼 수가 있으니까. 그래서 여기서 나오는 게
그거예요. 그거 하고도 이제 또 개인들도
사게끔 못 나가서 이제
국채를 사게끔 하는 거하고 총동원
이죠. 연준, 큐이 다시 하는 거예요.
연준도 총동원해서 다 사는 거예요.
그리고 은행들, 은행들도
규제 다 풀어주는 거예요. 사야 되니까.
지금도 보면은 미국도
은행 규제 계속 풀어주고 있잖아요. 네.
장기 국채를 사게끔.
사는 방향으로 풀어주고 코인
세이블 코인 국채 사야죠.
총동원, 총동원.
뭐든지 미국도 사게. 뭐든지.
그런 식으로 가는 거예요. 지금도 약간은 비슷하게
가고 있는 거예요. 네. 6가지 적었는데 이 중에서
자본통제 빼놓고 어느 정도는
약간은 가고 있죠. 지금.
지금도 국채를 사게끔
만드는 게 중요한 상황이니까. 네.
그런데 꼭 그 방법밖에 없나?
금융업 말고 딴 거 있지 않을까?
그래서 한번 찾아봤더니
국채를 해결하는 세 가지 방법이 나오긴 해요.
네. 첫 번째 우리가 제일 많이 해요. 긴축.
우리도 그러잖아요. 허리띠 졸라
메라. 지금 됐으면 어떻게 하냐.
이게 되게 좋은 얘기인 것 같잖아요. 네.
그런데 이 세 가지 방법 중에 이거는 아무도
선택하지 않아. 이걸 선택한 국가가
과거에 있었어요. 1998년에
한국이. 아이예프. 네.
다 갖다 팔고. 강요 아닙니까?
강요긴 했지만 어쨌든 이걸 하자고 했잖아요.
금 모으고. 금 모으기.
다 구조조정하고. 아랑아동동. 헐값으로 다 팔고.
했잖아요. 저희 아버지 직장 잃으시고.
네. 저도 마찬가지예요.
최선의 방법인가요?
이거는 잘 안 해요.
긴축을 주장한 정권들은 지금 다 지배하고 있어요.
그럼요. 영국의 순악총리
지배 갔죠. 누구 더 하겠어요. 프랑스도
지배하기 일보 직전이죠. 작년, 재작년에
시위여서 다 쫓아.
왜냐하면 이게 그럴 수밖에 없는 게
지금 20년, 30년 동안 빚을 졌잖아요. 국가가.
그런데 그거는 사실 누가 썼습니까?
아버지 세대가 쓴 거예요. 부모님 세대가.
그렇고 이제부터 허리띠 졸라매고
갚는 거는 젊은 세대들이 해야 되니까.
안 되지. 당연히 난리가 나죠.
그럼요. 채무자들한테
투표권을 주고. 네.
빚 갚을래? 하니까. 벨리가.
맞아요. 채권자들한테 투표권을 줬으면
될 텐데. 네.
갚아야 될 사람들한테 이렇게 투표해서
뽑아라 그러면 빚 갚는다고 하는
사람을 잘 안 뽑아주니까.
게다가 내가 쓴 것도 아닌데. 네.
약간 그런 생각이 들 수가 있는 거예요. 그렇지. 그렇지.
사실 뭐라고 할 수는 없어요. 맞는 얘기거든요.
그럼 이건 안 돼. 긴초. 네. 난리죠.
탈락. 두 번째 디폴트 있어요. 디폴트.
배째를 안 갚는다는 거죠.
근데 이거는 사실
디폴트를 선호하는 주체들을
보면요. 대부분 아주
약소국은 몇 개 빼고는 정부가 선택하는 경우는 거의 없어요.
대부분 개인이나
기업만 디폴트 선택하죠.
왠지 아세요? 정부는 왜 이걸 선택 안 하는지
아세요? 특히 기축통화국가들은. 가오 때문에.
아니요. 찍으면 되는 거 아닐까요? 정답입니다.
그렇지. 내가 발권력이 있거든요.
오 맞네. 만약에 뭐 이번에 너무
금리가 올라서 이자가 10조
입니다. 근데 돈이 없습니다.
그럼 어떻게 프린트하면 며칠 걸릴 것 같아?
물어보는 거죠. 그럼 찍어. 그럼 오늘부터 찍어.
일주일 걸리면 일주일 전부터 찍어줘.
10조 잘 썼습니다. 갖다 주는 거예요.
왜 그렇게 10조 찍으면 오래 걸리니까
한 장에. 10조?
그래. 수표 만들어.
찍어. 딸 깡.
대통령 깡이신데요.
위험. 찍지도 말고
클릭으로 보내자.
계좌로. 10조.
한국 대통령 말고 미국 대통령. 좀 더 줘.
11조. 이렇게.
미국 대통령이야? 미국 대통령.
트럼프 후계자로. 아 후계자로? 보내버리려고?
최초의 한인
미국 대통령.
한국에 관세 0% 해줄게요.
미국 대통령 되면.
어쨌든 그래서
딴 얘기로 했었는데
세 번째밖에 못하는 거예요. 금융화.
역사 볼까요? 고대 로마제국부터
지금까지 이것만 했어요.
이것 말고는 방법이 없거든.
수천 년 동안 사람들이 여러 가지 생각을 해봤는데 이것 말고는
방법이 없어.
심지어 경제를 몰랐던 우리나라도
상평통보.
찍어냈잖아요.
처음에 잘 괜찮았죠.
부처가 많아지고 하니까. 찍어야죠. 어떻게 해요.
중국에도 저런 거 많았죠. 돈으로 찍어서.
경제를 몰라도
직관적으로 이거 말고는 내가 살아날 방법이 없다.
찍어라.
이게 이거 말고는
어떤 신인류가 나타나서 새로운 방법을
구하는지 모르겠지만 아직까지는
물론 AI 해가지고 디플릿 시대가 오고
생산성이 높아져서
뭐가 먼저 오냐. 싸움이겠죠.
아무래도 그게 오기는 조금 시간이
걸릴 수 있지 않을까.
이제 결론입니다.
투자에 가는 거예요. 이렇게 하면 되게 좋겠네
라고 할 수 있지만
이거를 마음껏 선택하지 못해요.
그러면 돈 빌려주는 국가들이 가만히 있겠습니까?
실질금리가 15%에서
20%인데 돈 다 빼는 거예요.
내국인 돈은 못 갖고
나가게 할 수 있지만 외국인 돈을
못 갖고 나가게 할 수 없어요. 전쟁이거든요.
못 갖고 나가게 하더라도
그다음부터는 절대 안 넣겠죠. 저기를 좀
띄운다는 생각에. 그럼 어떻게 합니까?
통화가치가 하락을 하는 거예요.
그 국가의 통화가치는
엄청난 속도로 하락을 하는 거예요.
미국이 달러 패권을 잃을 거냐. 거기까지
갈 수는 없어요. 왜냐하면 그걸 성공적으로 하면
패권을 잃지는 않거든요. 그러니까 그것까지는 모르지만
어쨌든 약세를 가는 거는 막기 힘든 거예요.
그래서 과거에 그런 위기들이
사실 있었죠. 아, 달러 약세.
달러 약세가 바로 비슷한 위기일 수도 있고
좀 다를 수도 있지만 그런 일들이
과거에도 벌어졌었죠. 중요한 건
이거예요. 이게 되면 어떻게 되는지 아세요?
달러가 약세되면요?
유튜브 수입이 떨어집니다.
그치. 그치.
또 심각한 문제에 빠져들어요.
거의 뭐 경기 침체급의
위기 상황이 아닌가. 어? 다른
다른 걸 사고 싶어요.
달러 말고. 맞아요.
근데 이게 하나 더 생각하면
좋아요. 돈이 빠져나가겠죠.
돈이 빠져나면 중요한 건 이거예요. 돈이 어디로
가는지 우리가 봐야 돼요. 그래, 맞아. 돈은
왜냐하면 공중에 떠 있을 수가 없어요. 그렇다고 뭐
정기예금같이 이자 안 나온 데다
장기간 보관도 안 돼요. 안 해요.
어디론가 가야 돼, 그 돈은. 어디로 갔을까요?
이때, 과거에는. 아, 과거에?
1970년대
원자재. 원자재. 80년대 후반
제조업 신흥국.
아, 코스피 10배? 이건 다 10배예요.
어디로 가든. 어디로 가든 10배. 기본 10배야.
기본 10배. 아, 원자재는 이만?
원자재는 10배도 넘죠. 그래서 사실은
그때가 되면 어떤 거대한
투자의 시대의 서막이죠.
어, 돈이 움직이니까. 그렇죠.
빨리 제발 올려주세요. 10년간
벌 수 있는. 선생님, 제발. 그렇죠.
음. 방송 끄고 저한테 올려주세요.
저도, 저도 찾고 있어요.
아직은 저도 잘 몰라요. 오늘 자료에
쓴 건 있어요. 몇 가지
후보는 있을 수 있다. 후보, 후보 알려주세요.
지금 투자하면 안 되고, 이건 나중에 이제
이런 현상이 벌어졌을 때. 아, 벌어졌을 때.
벌어진 이후죠. 왜냐면 벌어지고 한 번, 한 1년
정도는 아마 굉장히 큰 부침을 겪을 거니까.
음. 일단은
빚달러 자산들 선택해야겠죠. 만약에
미국에서 그런 사태가 터진다는 가정 하에
지금 보는 거니까. 일단 첫 번째는
빚달러. 두 번째는
원자재 수입 의존도가 높은 나라.
유가나 이런 그, 원유나 이런 거
수입 의존도가 높은 나라. 대만. 한국이잖아요.
일본. 한국. 어, 뭐
여러 나라가 있죠. 굉장히 많죠. 룰벨 상당
국가들도 그렇게 되고, 아시아 국가는 대부분이고요.
어, 그리고 또 하나는
저는 부채 비율이, 정부 부채 비율이
그렇게 높지 않은 나라. 한국. 우리
어, 어, 어. 그러니까 이. 코스피 랜드
알고 싶지. 일단 두터이 까.
계속, 계속 코스피. 남다.
아니, 원자재 수입 넣고. 코스피 6만?
어, 물론 저는 우리나라 했으면 너무 좋겠어요. 아직까지는
몰라요. 그때 가서 이제 상황들을 봐야죠.
누가 치고 올라갈지. 일단은 이제
우리 이거 알고 있는 것만으로도
도움이 돼요. 왜냐면은 이런 현상들이
벌어지면은. 맞아. 굉장히 힘든 구간이
있겠지만, 그 구간에 우리가 이런 생각을 할 수
있잖아. 어, 이게 지금. 그것도
기회잖아. 정신 똑바로 차려야 돼. 뭐 이런 것들.
왜냐면 큰 기회가 있을 수 있다.
이런 생각을 할 수 있는 거죠. 아, 아, 아.
정신, 우리 정신 똑바로 차릴 수 있게 좀
자주 와서 얘기해. 쟤 쉬었음 계좌도 어떻게 좀.
쉬면 안 돼. 계좌가.
이 기회를 잡아야 돼. 자꾸 계좌가. 계좌가
확 쉬어버리네. 그러면. 어.
그, 거기 계좌에 있는 거를.
어. 싫어요. 예?
무슨. 빚 달러?
그게 원하잖아. 그치.
다 원하잖아. 나쁘지 않은
결론인 것 같기도 하고요. 지금이 아니고.
아, 지금이 아니고.
지금은 좀 있어야 되는구나.
지금이 아니고. 지금 달러가 좋았던 거
아닌가. 아, 그러니까 지금은 달러가 있어야 되는데.
그러면 뭐, 섹터 같은 건 뭐
광통신이라든지. 예를 들면 그런 거.
아니, 아니. 그러니까. 10년 얘기하는데
광통신이 왜 나와있어.
섹터 같은 게 앞으로 유명한. 한강통신이다.
한강통신. 그러니까. 오늘의 광통신이야.
있을 수 있잖아요. 딱 이사님이 보시는.
쓰리광, 비광이다. 무슨 광통신.
그림으로 보는 딱 섹터.
업종으로도 다음에
아, 뭐야.
다음 시간에 한 번 더 보시라 이런 거죠.
일단은 뭐야.
오늘 준비를 안 했어요. 답답합니다. 답답합니다.
답답합니다. 예, 알겠습니다.
저는 얘기를 쭉 들어보니까
머리 속이 복잡해지면서
코를 사야 되나. 코스피가 더 갈 수 있지
않나 하는 기대감도 약간 있는데
중간에 한 번 위기가 온다고 그랬거든요.
그때는 용기를 내서
이번에는 용기를 내서
놓치지 않도록. 근데 만약에 이제
위기가 왔어. 그러면 이제 뭐
법인계좌에 한 10억이 있어. 예를 들면.
그럼 그 10억으로 어디에 투자하실 거예요?
쫄아서 예금할 거 같은데.
아, 그러니까.
돈을 못 벗나니까.
어떻게 해서 위기가 왔는데.
금융위기 몇 년 지속된 줄 알아요?
그럼 위기가 오면 법인계좌는 저에게 맡겨주십시오.
네가 더 위기야?
제가 우주항공, 광통신,
AI, 전기, 전력
이렇게 나눠서 살 수 있는.
고양이에 업물점 맡긴다는 말이 있었거든요.
아, 진짜. 예금 맡기는 것보다는
낫지.
자, 됐고요. 알겠습니다.
폭풍격방송 주식은 지금
자, 오늘 2부는
아, 정말 수준 높은. 이해됐어요?
금융어박.
어박이 아니라.
아주 수준 높은 얘기였는데.
주의 깊게 다시 한 번 들어보시면은.
천천히 들어보시면은.
완전 고퀄리티 강이에요. 여러분.
아유. 오늘 1부에 나와주신
우리 연구원님. 다시 한 번 감사드립니다.
감사합니다. 이사님 감사합니다. 이사님 또 나와주실 거죠?
다들 이렇게 되면.
보통 안 나오겠다는 말을.
내가 성원이한테 얘기할게.
성원이한테.
성원아, 야. 안 나온다는데?
압박 좀 해봐. 압박 좀.
미국 대통령 얘기하고 이상하던데 이럴 수 있어?
그 프로 이상하던데 이럴 수 있어?
자, 좋습니다. 폭풍격방송 주식은 지금.
자, 오늘 시장은 좀 잔잔했는데요.
1부에서 정말 인사이트 된
얘기가 아니었나 생각합니다.
다음 주에도 더욱 인사이트 된 내용으로 여러분과 함께하겠습니다.
여러분 다시 한 번 감사드립니다.
안녕. 감사합니다.